for the Arab world annual get-together
this year the leaders converged on
Algiers some representing countries in
turmoil others locked in a standoff over
power while many governed societies
struggling with dire social and economic
challenges
the conflict and crises are not just
within Arab countries the level of
representation was a sign of the uneasy
relationships among each other
Algeria says the Gathering is about
reunifying the Arab League but the
normalization of ties between Israel and
some Arab countries has further
polarized it and while leaders voiced
messages of support for Palestinian
rights and statehood the Gathering ended
without condemnation of Israel
dear brothers or Palestinian people are
facing racist policies with our
challenges we are expecting from you to
follow up to pursue your position by
activating the previous resolutions of
the Arab Summits
those taking part in the summit face the
challenge of crafting a final resolution
agreed by all a point of contention has
long been the role of non-arab actors
turkia and Iran the final communique
called for non-interference in Arab
Affairs and an end to the presence of
foreign forces but unlike some leaders
it didn't mention names
it wasn't the only divisive issue put
aside there was no agreement on Syria's
return to the Arab fold after more than
a decade of exclusion due to its brutal
Crackdown on Peaceful protests Syria's
reinstatement was something Russia had
been pushing for but it does appear to
have won another diplomatic battle the
Arab League didn't isolate Moscow and
remained neutral in the Ukraine conflict
in turn President Vladimir Putin told
the league Russia is ready to cooperate
with them to boost their security
the war in Ukraine has also affected
economies an increase in food and fuel
prices has worsened hunger in the Middle
East and North Africa and while Russia
may have reversed its decision to
suspend participation in the effort to
allow Ukraine to export grains it caused
concern we must do all we can to ensure
the continued success of the Black Sea
Green initiative to provide relief to
those in need geopolitical divides have
created a new reality in the Middle East
and North Africa where Russia and China
are gaining influence at the expense of
the U.S the final communique supported
the decision by OPEC plus to reduce oil
output which caused tensions between
Saudi Arabia and the United States but
many see it as the Revival of the old
Regional order where leaders use words
like Unity solidarity and Joint action
without offering solutions to the crises
Algiers